- Let's pull up today's dose
of the joy from the inter webs.
Y'all this is 'What I'm Liking'.
(Upbeat intro music)
Some people have pet dogs,
others have cats or snakes,
even pigs, but one woman named Faith, in
San Diego has gone another direction.
One of her pets is a 19 pound
mini horse named Peabody.
Which is so cute.
Peabody was born the runt
of the litter, and he was
in danger of being euthanized.
Faith trains mini horses
to be therapy animals. So
she decided to take him in,
and he's doing better than
she could've ever guessed.
We have Faith on the line right now,
along with little Peabody.
They watch the show on
NBC 7, San Diego. What's up y'all?
Oh my gosh.
If that does not bring joy
in your heart, you are dead.
Oh my God. Peabody, you are so...
So tell us how Peabody
was, whenever you got him.
- You know, I, I got him at
2 old and he couldn't walk.
He couldn't eat because
his jaw was out of line.
He was deaf. They thought he was blind.
And I thought, well, they're
going to put him down.
I'm going to take them
home and we'll give it a
shot, because he had a real will to live.
- He is the cutest
little guy on the planet.
So, Peabody's come a long way since you
got him though, right?
- Oh, it's, Kelly, its like a miracle.
We found some special
shoes and we put them
on him, and we changed
them every couple weeks.
He is running around the
house now. We have, his
head has actually grown. So his
jaw is aligned. He's eating.
And his eyesight is really good.
And they say he's still
deaf, but I don't know.
He might have selective hearing.
But he makes people smile.
He has over 300 million
views on the internet.
And I get calls from all over the world.
There was one lady and she had polio.
She said that when she saw
Peabody with his new shoes,
stomping down that wood floor,
trying so hard, that it gave
her real purpose and it
motivated her. And she said,
"I got out of bed". And she said,
"I just started walking
again." So he just makes.
What I do is train miniature
horses for therapy, and we like
to go visit, but I never
dreamed that I would
be able to find a little horse, that would
be a therapy horse for the world.
- Oh my God. Peabody.
Oh my God. You are adorable.
You have made me smile on
the inside, man. Well done.
Thank you so much Faith for
sharing Peabody with us.
Alright. I'm liking your posts right now.
(Audience Applause)
Well, that's not all,
our season long partner
Pilot penned the Goats,
who penned to the Kelly
Clarkson Show, thinks that what
you're doing is incredible.
So in recognition,
there'll be using their G2 gel
ink pen to write you a check
for a thousand dollars. How's that sound?
- Oh my gosh. Thank you so much.
Did you hear that Peabody?
- Absolutely.
- Thank you.
- Peabody is getting some new shoes y'all.